this is what heaven would look like to
me okay this is hanging out with my old
man
my pops how you doing visiting the
family here in Texas and he makes this
dish which seriously it's heavenly if
you haven't had it can you guess what
this is called can you guess what that
is called oh my gosh if you haven't had
that yet it's called Alma sabzi my
Persian people will know what it is
Dilli here sit with Daddy let's talk -
lets talked about your payment together
is that okay just do it send are you
okay - you wanna join us - come on Billy
get in it as well let's do the three of
us okay say I say hello shake hello
hello my little mohawk there you go
Billy say hello to everybody okay Billy
can you tell him what our focus is ready
Billy I Dylan James be David's well one
day be a great leader
daddy do we bully people do people bully
us nope because we're what we lead we
love we respect we improve right you
noted that once I'm sitting next to
these kids
my oldest is over there hanging out with
his mommy and
what do you want to say you want to say
something are we gonna take over the
world or what who are you dilly who are
you gonna be one that when you grow up a
superhero who tell us what you gonna be
flash Wow whose daddy who are you gonna
be spider-man whose daddy credible halt
not incredible credible hug whose tease
Tico ah he's Superman yeah what and what
are we gonna do together we're gonna
take over the what we didn't take over
the world together I'm gonna join you on
that journey pop okay okay
Center gonna go with us as well yeah
senator go choo
now you're gonna be have an outfit like
this because I don't know if that's
gonna work pop with this underwear you
got on daddy we got it we got to do
something about that okay you gonna and
you're gonna need to go get your
superhero outfit you know it's amazing
I'm talking to these guys today oh go
get it go work with mommy and bring you
back go go show me show me your muscles
I'm talking to these guys today and
we're just hanging out and one of the
things that came to my mind is that
sometimes as we age we lose one thing
let me tell what that one thing is we
lose that level of innocence innocence
leaves us we no longer are innocent like
a child we're no longer innocent like a
kid who thinks we can trip over the
world we're no longer thinking like
someone who is thinking anything and
everything is capable of we can pull up
anything we can pull off a miracle right
daddy be careful daddy send us a small
papa
here sit next to Daddy say hello to
everybody here sit and say hello to
everybody
what's your name Patrick full name
okay what are the four four things we
follow that out what are the four things
do we bully yeah do we get bullied
that's right so he comes up to me today
he says your daddy I'm your the Captain
America right and then he says Dylan is
who Dylan is spider-man and then daddy
is incredible hall and then we're gonna
go take over the world together right
now that thinking as adults is so we say
things like oh that's so cute you know
it's so amazing think like that as
adults anymore why do we lose that lose
a little innocence
why do we lose that level of thinking
anything is possible why do we lose that
level of childlike thinking that you
know you you're you're thinking
emotionally and validating logically
instead of everything having to be
logically making sense I know you're
gonna be spider-man
daddy you meet amazing spider-man Ryan
and you didn't be a creative boho am I
gonna be a good incredible home yeah
okay that's good
we're gonna be who's your best friend
tico who loves you to go I think Miss
Moore loves you too no way wow that's
awesome
I miss more pictures love
who believes in you I mean everyone
that's so amazing isn't it I said me and
every it's always said I never joke I
love your show Joe Wow Joe James Joe Joe
Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe how do you people
you want to say hi to your friends once
you say hi to Sonia Gracie let me say hi
to Shannon Gracie no Shannon Gracie okay
let's finish this video part so we can
get back to what we're doing so the
point is this hanging out with these
kids ignites ignites the level of
innocence that we have to believe that
anything is possible so instead of being
so logical and having everything needing
to make sense to logically use a little
bit of your innocence emotional sign
excitement enthusiasm to believe that
everything's gonna work out and if you
keep that thinking eventually things
will work out your way
I know it's childlike I know it's not
adult like I know it's not logically
educated proper type of thinking but I
hate to say it anyone that ever does
anything big they have a certain level
of childlike innocence in them that the
rest do not have anyways I gotta let you
go take over the world again
you won't watch one pop you went to Star
War I don't see Star War up there
babe what Star Wars they talking about
up there okay I gotta go thank you
everybody
good night